[Musique]
y'a plus qu'à choisir indispensable mais
souvent sans aucun style les poubelles
prennent toujours plus franches ont des
cultures et j'ai joué je regarde revient
à un portage de plus belle
le prix varie entre 80 et 200 euros 200
euros n'aura attend 200 euros 200 euros
pour une poubelle attend une poubelle ça
avait un truc quand tu prends un sou tu
mets des chaînes lancé une poubelle dans
un bourg de géo c'est parce que tu
prends mais il faut que la 200 euros
pour une poubelle nombre d'oiseaux sont
des poubelles qui ont été redessinés
entièrement par frédéric carillo aussi
c'est frédéric perrigault que les
audacieux alors lanthemann 200 euros et
pour augmenter sa bonne humeur
rien de tel que certains détails comme
un joint antimoderne pour ce genre de
poubelles il faut compter un minimum de
198 euros on propose dans cette vidéo de
faire le point sur les différents
capitaux que nous possédons et qui
détermine nos goûts tout de suite plus
numérique
[Musique]
pierre bourdieu distingue trois types de
capitaux le capital économique doit être
peu défini par ce qu'il a déjà été
beaucoup travaillé et tout le monde
comprend de quoi il s'agit le capital
économique peut être hérité capitale
économique peut être aussi acquis si
c'est moi même qui crée de la richesse
ou simplement qui gagne ma vie en ayant
un salaire à côté de ce capital
économique bourdieu va bien travailler
sur le capital culturel
il s'inspira un petit peu du des travaux
d culturaliste du courant culturaliste
comme basile bernstein alors le capital
culturel on peut le diviser en trois
sous type
tout d'abord il ya le capital culturel
institutionnalisée ça c'est le plus
facile à comprendre ce sont les diplômes
évidemment si j'ai un diplôme
universitaire on va considérer que j'ai
plus de capitale culturelle que
quelqu'un qui a simplement un diplôme de
secondaire mais à côté de ce capital
culturel institutionnalisé qui n'est pas
tout il y à du capital culturel
incorporez c'est tout ce que je veut
emmagasiner pendant la socialisation
primaire voir ma socialisation
ultérieure mais pendant imprime en
france je vais vraiment acquérir des
façons de penser des modes de
raisonnement du vocabulaire une façon de
me till façon d'aix de m'exprimer qui va
trahir finalement mon origine sociale
tout le capital culturel va transpirer
finalement parce capitale culturelle
incorporé à côté de ce capital culturel
incorporel il ya un capital culturel
objective et ça va être l'ensemble des
objets des choses qui m'appartiennent et
qui vont trahir de mon niveau de capital
le nombre de livres le type de livre que
je possède les lectures que l'on a mais
aussi les meubles qu'on qui peuvent
eux-mêmes trahir d'un certain capital
les oeuvres d'art évidemment sont tous
des éléments qui me permet d'objectiver
le capital culturel d'un individu le
capital culturel comme le capital
économique peut être hérité ou acquis
enfin le dernier type de capital qui est
proposée par pierre bourdieu et le
capital social c'est l'ensemble des
relations et des liens que je peux
établir avec d'autres personnes avec
d'autres milieux évidemment ici
la qualité des liens va être plus
importante que la quantité ne s'agit pas
d'avoir deux mille amis sur facebook
mais plutôt d'un réseau de relations qui
me permettra d'acquérir de nouvelles
ressources culturelles ou économiques
évidemment le type de capital social va
varier d'un champ à l'autre pour
bourdieu un chant et une dimension de la
société dans le champ de la boucherie
évidemment il est plus intéressant de
connaître des bouchers des charcuter des
intermédiaires les personnes qui
travaillent dans les circuits
alimentaires que de connaître par
exemple des professeurs de géographie
ces capitaux mis ensemble vont conférer
un certain statut social aux individus
qui les possèdent cela on va l'appeler
le capital symbolique le capital
symbolique c'est finalement la
possibilité pour un individu d'étaler
ses ressources et de les utiliser afin
d'établir des normes au sein de la
société
l'individu qui a dû capital symbolique
où la classe dominante qui a dû capital
symbolique va pouvoir par ses choix
imposé la norme
ces choix sont la norme non pas parce
qu'ils sont justifiées par quelques
arguments mais simplement parce que la
possession du capital symbolique permet
d'établir la norme par le simple choix
évidemment est un corollaire à ça qui
est celui de la violence symbolique et
je vous propose la vidéo ici pour faire
le point sur ce concept
imaginons le village de saint tropez qui
ressemble finalement à beaucoup de
villages de la côte d'azur mais par le
seul fait que saint-tropez a été choisi
par la classe dominante ayant un capital
symbolique dans plusieurs champs on peut
penser au champ économique ou dans le
star system un saint tropez va être
choisi dans les années 60 comme de place
to be et le simple fait de ce choix va
donner à saint tropez le véritable
statut de place to be si vous voulez
cette vidéo est fini je vous remercie
pour votre attention je vous propose de
poster vos commentaires pour qu'on
puisse évidemment préciser les éléments
de cette vidéo ou en débattre et je vous
dis à très bientôt pour une prochaine
vidéo consacrée à distinction de pierre
bourdieu
[Musique]
pascal pénale de saint-jérôme on s'en
fout que ce design et comment ça pour
que ça soit sortie dans ta cuisine 100
foot à priser cumulé des échecs dans ta
poubelle pas pour que ce soit joli quoi
pas fait pour donne moi les 200 euros
donnés moi tu vas voir ce que je vais en
faire des 200 euros
si tu veux jouer à même de dessiner une
poubelle le même temps décidé de je
dessinais une poubelle et un gobelet
[Musique]
du 100 euros
oh
200 boules pour une poubelle choquant